now I have a I have a question was the
Press gay back then like they are
now to answer your question no they
really weren't gay
Shane I don't agree with using gay that
way he's even making me sound gay
because I'm so upset with him my
God
so well like kronite kronite was a
picture funny to actually be gay when
you're being gay it's the best like to
be mad about something get a coaster for
that stop it stop it especially this
angry gay stop it Shane what's more
terrify that would be if you had two gay
dads there would have been one he was
like Shane just don't make him mad Shane
what the [__] are you saying to him
Shane it just reminds me and I this
isn't presidential but this is one of
the funniest things Nick talo ever said
to me I know I made fun of him in the
last one so I want to I want to praise
him he's I love the guy he's like my
brother we used to live together and I I
was telling him about this thing that I
had heard about the thing about Nick
depalo is that you say you tell him
about something and he finds the joke so
the thing I told him about was that
there's somewhere in Asia they they they
love monkey brains and the best way to
enjoy monkey brains is when they're
still alive so what there's these tables
with little like skull-shaped holes in
them and they put the monkey up there
and they cut the top of and you just cut
it open and you eat it with a little
stylish fork and I said this to Nick and
he's pretended being one of those guys
he's like I'm sing my back it's
[Laughter]
[__] like that would make it t back
this one's [__] I want my money back
here's a good piece of trivia and don't
look it up nope okay here's a a quiz
question who is who is uh Johnson Lynden
bains Johnson's vice president after
Kennedy was shot when he who became the
vice
president I your mother's [__] oh oh man
it wasn't her it wasn't it wasn't your
mother it was her kind of her
was wait a second dude there a History
Podcast yeah you're telling me Jones G
yeah because they only he only needed
her for one
year and then when he ran when he ran
excited to watch this then when he ran
he got somebody else but he was like he
called out Joan I need your [__] to be
my
vice he called her from Dallas you know
that famous picture of him on the plane
that was he called her right before that
I need your vagina to be my PR my VI
president all right so let's start from
the
top mom I'm so sorry that he said that
I'm not I never met your mom you
back so let's do this yeah we're GNA
read some
ads okay all right and then we're going
to switch over to the patreon for the
last part so join the patreon if you
want why do you switch why do you make
them go on patreon that way that way
what it's good you make you need the
money yes really the ads and the patreon
you're going to make him listen to ads
and then switch to patreon hold
on this is look this is like when I
watch a [__] fight on Doone which I
pay for and there's a [__] ad between
the rounds hold on is it subscription or
is it [__] ad [__] there's three ads
hold on you yeah you don't have to put
this on patreon we do you don't have to
you don't need the money Matt and Sean
need it how much mat got a family how
much do you get for patreon how much
really you I'll tell you tell me how
much do you think you'll make on this on
patreon if if 1,000 people join yeah the
patreon that's it's $5 a month it's
$5,000 a month and then you think they
just stay there and then yeah they like
it but you think a thousand people will
join your patreon 5,000 new
people because of this I wish you would
stop this guys support the greatest hist
,000 a month to keep this content fore
this could be America has never liked
gets two don't touch me don't touch me
don't ever put your [__] hands on me
I out of [__] hands on me I'm going
to grip you up God damn it hold
on so Jefferson Jefferson shut the [__]
up guys shut up guys Sean get out Sean
don't look at me here's a great Kennedy
story so Peter Salinger I think his name
was Pierre Salinger one of the he was a
great he was a um a journalist who hung
out with Kennedy a lot so they're in
Kennedy's um in the Oval Office and what
Kennedy really liked bragging about was
that he could get anybody on the phone
ever the White House operators could get
any human being in the world so he said
to Pierre Salinger
um give me a name I can get him on the
phone in 10 minutes and he happened to
know that Truman capot was uh writing a
book in the woods he was like in a cabin
in the woods cut off no phone on
sabatical and so he says Truman capot
and so Kennedy get picks up the phone on
the coffee table says yeah give me a
Truman capot please and just hangs up
and then they keep talking and in 10
minutes he hears like a h like they
[__] got a helicopter and they
lowered it and yes Mr
President M the constitution of the
Commonwealth of
Massachusetts is like the most liberal
document in the world because Adams was
like he's like I'm going to get it right
everything that I couldn't get done in
the American Constitution I'm doing in
this and there's stuff in there about
Jews having rights there's even
something about gay people in there like
he was into gay rights Jews pretty gay
back then pretty gay pretty Jewish to be
a gay Jew it's gay to be into
Jews to be into Jewish rights in the
1700s was gay those Parliament
undeniably gayen back then I don't know
what about Jews people like get the [__]
out of here Jew back then have a room
full of dude in powder wigs being
like and the Jews looked exactly that
they look the same as they do now the
big black coats exact same outfit same
outfit same way when I was a kid I lived
in Mexico and uh from when I was I know
I
know I know like I'm aware that's like
not Pennsylvania crushes Mexico yes you
guys are dying to get to PA dude yes and
I got obsessed with the idea of the
president of the United States it's
where it became a thing to me and the
president at the time was Nixon I cut a
picture out of him of him out of the
paper and I put it taped it up next to
my bed yes I loved
when I was a little kid I was so about
Richard Nixon and I wrote a letter to my
Abita my grandma and I sent her a
picture of Nixon said this is the
president of United States he's the
greatest man greatest man in the country
he so cool he's the best I didn't know a
single thing about him and he had this
serious face and I had a dream it's the
first Dream I remember I the my bedroom
was in the front of our house so you
looked out at the front of our house and
it I was asleep and it was like a Sunday
morning and I heard a band like a
marching band
and I looked outside and it was
Nixon like walking up my street just no
no Spectators yeah just him walking up
with followed by a marching
man and I came out on the front yard I
we had this walkway and he got down on
one knee and he said
Louie and I ran into his
arms what the
[__] damn you love
I led him so
[Laughter]
much D isn't that
crazy I've never told anybody that you
know I've never told anybody that in my
life and so
l
[Music]
like oh and it's funny
there's the idea of his Joy cuz Nixon
was such a miserable man that his Joy
side was very rare there's only one time
I've ever seen it on film and it's when
he's playing piano he's in a tuxedo and
I think he's at his daughter's wedding
and he was a concert pianist he was very
good and he's playing piano and he plays
some big Crescendo and he's got this big
dumb grin on his face and I think maybe
I had seen that cuz that's the only that
grin every time I see it I'm in that
dream so but my parents saw that I had
these pictures of him next to my bed and
they were like he's not a good he's not
that great not cuz Watergate was
happening and every night my parents
were sitting in front of the TV this
little [__] color TV watching
Watergate watching the hearings and it
was like sh and like yeah I'm like how's
my boy going how's he doing yeah and
Nixon's resignation was just like a
depressing uh destroying sad [__] up
thing it was just like what now over cuz
when we lost the Cil War when the when
we lost the Civil War I don't know what
made me say that no when
the when the South lost the Civil War
you got to cut that part where I say we
lost cut that I don't know
what immediately this is pretty sick
1893 Cleveland gets reelected yeah
people El his hot daughter and now their
new daughter or his hot bride wife yeah
and now their New Daughter Baby
Ruth okay you know the candy bar yeah
yeah but isn't that bab no I think it's
named after their daughter you don't
think it's named after Babe Ruth you got
to look that up is
it feels closer to True did they even
have candy bars back
then look man you
know you know who Mounds was named after
your mother's gun had a feeling I had a
strong
feeling what says uh the candy bar was
named after Ruth Cleveland I like that
took place in 1921 check Mounds okay
check Mounds see if Mounds was named
after my mother's [__] okay I mean it's
just sad Shane what if it says M what if
it says Mrs
CK what if there's a Twist maybe I'm
projecting a great story about Teddy the
way where teddy bears come
from okay Teddy Roosevelt was on in
Pennsylvania again your [__] State
might have been inred St not much
difference so um Teddy was there and uh
on tour as president and there were some
people you know every time the president
comes to a town they always like they
get so excited and they plan stuff so
they knew he loves hunting Bear yeah so
when when Teddy hunts bear he's way up
in a mountain alone with a gun and it's
him and the bear and he might die yeah
but these people think he's like a
gentleman Hunter so they take him we're
going to take you to hunt some bear and
they give him a gun and they take him
into the woods and there's a bear
chained to a tree a little bear who's
kind of emaciated and it was chained to
a tree and they go shoot
him and Teddy breaks down into tears
yeah and he says for the love of God let
that poor animal go and there was some
journalist there who drew a picture that
was like a little sketch that was in the
paper of Teddy with this and this little
bear and it was they put the people put
that together Teddy and bear uh and
started making these stuffed bears that
look like Teddy because of this Jesus
Christ another great story about him
that I heard was that uh he would fight
whoever was the heavyweight champ oh
yeah he would bare knuckle yeah so like
Jack Johnson I think had just won the
championship so he was invited he
doesn't know this what's going to happen
he was invited to the White House so he
I don't know if they had an oval office
yet
yeah comes into the Oval Office believe
they did and Teddy was like oh terrific
and he [__] starts and Jack Johnson's
like what are you doing he's like come
on now because to him it was like it
made sense yeah that the President
should fight with the heavyweight
champion D and he fought him and Johnson
uh blinded him in one eye and Teddy
begged him please don't tell anybody cuz
I'll get it cuz Teddy he's not supposed
to do this so he used to get people to
leave the room
and then he fought him and he BL he was
always blinding that eye which he was
always in denial about because he was
sort of ashamed that he did this thing
yeah this guy's
insane
I I stopped guy with a G Gro it's either
Grover Cleveland or Garfield one of
those two was shot and killed yeah uh
McKinley shot and killed JFK and Lincoln
nice four shot and killed Reagan [__]
close badly shot yeah uh uh uh Roosevelt
Teddy shot in the chest bull uh but had
a a spe a thick piece of paper with his
speech and a glasses finished the speech
dude yep finished the speech got shot
was like uh and somebody shot at at um
um Jack Andrew Jackson yeah you and he
had a cane and he beat the guy beat the
[__] out of the guy I almost beat him to
death the guy shot shot him and he just
get the [__] right outside the the
capital what like by the big uh pillars
or whatever and he just beat the [__]
[__] out he was in insane but yeah like
over 10 like 12% ENT of them had been
shot have been shot so it's an intense
job pretty there's a good chance it is
like a higher rate than actual soldiers
in war oh yeah well I don't know it's
probably I guess so I bet it is might be
[__] up yeah cuz in like regular like
Revolution [__] is like 70,000 soldiers
2,000 dead what's crazy is but before it
used to be like when you know you like
uh uh what's his name Alexander the
Great and whoever some Kings used to
lead heads of state used to lead charges
used to be the front horse like going
right headlong into an army that would
be nice to be a guy Roman Roman guys did
that jackpot yeah [__] got him holy
[__] he's coming right at me he's coming
right BW just some
guy then the other great thing was at
Yalta the conference at Yalta where yeah
this is good
FDR and Churchill are trying to get
Stalin to come into the war on the
Allied he could have come in either side
it was a tossup or he could have stayed
out but a Russian front to the war was
everything it turned out to be
everything yeah same thing that happened
to it's What stopped uh uh it's what
killed Napoleon because Russia is just
this deep forest and anybody who invades
Russia just gets absorbed and then stuck
for the winter it killed Napoleon and it
killed eventually took Hitler it's not
where they lose but it's where they get
they drains okay yeah so Churchill is
like the European Statesman he's the one
who's been fighting the war longer and
he's like he's been mechanizing how am I
going to do this and so when they get to
Yalta he goes to to Roosevelt and says
let's talk let's plan how we're going to
get uh Joseph and um FDR goes oh just
let's have lunch we'll do after lunch
after lunch and he's like okay when are
we gonna We got to comfab you and me we
got to triangulate we're going to you
come from that good cop bad cop like
which one do you want to do and FDR is
like it's all right Winston it's all
right it's all right I got we we'll talk
about it we'll definitely talk about it
and then they're at lunch with
Stalin
and uh and Roosevelt looks at Churchill
and he says to Stalin Joseph look at
look at Churchill look at what a fat
weird little man he is what a look at
him with his cigar look how ridiculous
he is and Stalin is like shocked and he
looks at church and he
goes he just laughs and he [__] fing
drinks vodka with FDR and they [__]
singing songs and FDR and Joseph are
like best friends Churchill is a [__]
loser and then and then you know and FDR
is like so you come in our side and Jo
like yes yes I come in your side of
course I come in your side that's he
just read he read the room and he knew
what had to be done and it was throwing
[__] Winston Churchill into the bus
and making him feel like a fat little
[__] and he's mad about it mad
Churchill was mad yeah he like left
there no but he got the I mean he won
World War II with that yes he did but he
had to be humiliated yeah go as long as
we been talking an hour okay well you're
not enjoying us you're not having the
time of your life I'm having a great
time I knew you would this is nice right
I'm not having a great time you're not
having a great time no I'm not I hate
this decent time really no I'm having a
good time how much fun you decide which
one
um the Japanese were never going to
surrender yeah and the amount of people
that would have died this is what it's
like when you get deep into a war how
many people have died so far how many
more will die if we do it this way how
many will die if we do it this
way uh so that's what happened I don't
have an opinion about it I don't I do
but that's fine here's the thing here's
the thing nobody cares about Dresden
nobody cares about no Dresden way more
people di yeah and it's also and first
off kind of well not more horrifically
both had like fire tornadoes yeah that
just wiped out they set the atmosphere
on fire yeah it's the scariest thing in
the world it's awful it sucked the
oxygen out of a city and there were fire
tornadoes yes people were melting in the
streets yes into the street the the down
the drains the pavement melted so they'd
run out of their houses and their feet
would get stuck and then they'd reach
down and then just be stuck in the
[__] I mean it's the worst thing in
the world but but you
know they might have had it coming
but of course of course these are
civilians of course there's a joke about
two agents running to each other on the
street in Hollywood and one of them's
like uh hey what have you been up to and
he goes oh I produced a special for you
know whatever just pick a you know
Selene di or whatever you yeah he goes
how' you like working with her she's
like [__] [__] [__] worthless
[__] spoiled brat [__] drunk
[__] drug adult [__] I hope she
[__] dies and the other guy goes you
know she's my niece and the guy goes let
me
finish what um we left off at LBJ so LBJ
so LBJ
um first of all there's an
interesting tie in a person that ties
together JFK LBJ and Nixon is it my
mother's [__] it's your mother's C is it
really no it really wasn't godam
it no there is some parts of History
your mother's [__] did not figure into
there's only a
few if you ever go to 30 so 30 Rock
where I was almost there yeah you were
almost there but then you said something
terrible just terrible Shane how dare
you I just remembered get out of my
house oh shame on you Shane Gill I like
my SNL shame on you didn't get
cut